[Applause]  Grayson Allen pulls the trick the  opening quarter there's that behind the  back pass a betta Allen and launches a  rainbow for three jazz team is about  moving the basketball everybody knowing  where they're supposed to be second  three-ball  right now picking apart the Wildcat  thirty nine to eleven one first quarter  now he shows us his back at tricks Dante  works the point but get Scott  Allen on a catch and shoot his third  free of the rookies deep used with 11  points in the first half with a lighter  to 1 and a rack of basketballs run of it  [Applause]  calmly put this to bed downtown  they could come up with basketball  button racing cars on that followed by  Norton with eight and stylized vibration  Allen on the backside